à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regarde c'est ce fou de josé il nous
fait le même coup à chaque fois il est
malade ce type c'est pour nous faire
peur
on
bonjour la mort
essai de m'attraper pourvoir il
mon nom est josé guitare et je suis
pilote de fumigation cela fait dix ans
que je travaille dans les llanos en
colombie il ya ma passion c'est voler
nous les pilotes de fumigation nous
sommes une espèce rare car il faut avoir
du courage faut être raillon puisque
notre peau tous les jours
nous voulons un mètre du sol et à 200km
une erreur n'est pas permis tout des
centres aux études et craint un coup de
hanche de travers et ses fatah en plus
nous transportons un produit mortel
dans ce métier en décollant et
atterrissant 40 à 50 fois par jour
la rapidité dans le travail
c'est primordial au sol l'histoire
empire l'avion très vite et nettoyer une
partie du temps maximum au sol ne doit
pas dépasser 2 minutes c'est du temps
mort pour moi au sol je ne gagne rien
moi on me paye que lorsque je décolle
[Musique]
s'il n'y a pas d'assurance dans la
fumigation qui ne trouvera personne qui
veuille assurer disent que nous sentons
la mort
[Musique]
appelle moi le mécano s'il te plaît
mais en même temps et palacio man et 10
mois la pression du lait trop bas en
cabine j'ai l'impression qu'un tuyau
s'est rompu et si c'est le tuyau
d'essence s'affiche sans moteur et ça
peut exploser
c'est ça exactement
moi je le sentais trop accéléré
[Musique]
maria le café je suis désespérée lorsque
je n'ai pas de travail parce que je ne
donne pas cela m'ennuie et ça me fatigue
[Musique]
ces produits sont dangereux pour les
pilotes mais aussi pour les assistants
tous ceux qui les manipulent
mais ils sont nécessaires car si les
agriculteurs ne s'applique pas ils
perdent leur école
ça c'est mon sens tu dois passer aient
pu miser là tu vois
ok ça se le centre d'accord
il ya toujours de nouvelles espèces de
maladies et d'insectes qui se développe
et se régénère sur les cultures nous les
latino américains observons de cobaye
pour essayer les produits chimiques
qu'il lance sur le marché ces produits
qui sont interdits aux états unis en
europe il nous les envoient chez nous
[Musique]
ces produits sont très toxiques
puisqu'il tue les insectes et les
mauvaises herbes
c'est un travail délicat il faut très
professionnelle pour appliquer les doses
avec précision car tu peut détruire
toute la faune autant
en fait nous en pause la non les
cultures il ya de bonnes récoltes
moi c'est à cause de cette vermine de
chauny que nous sommes obligés de figer
les champs de soja
sinon elle détruit toutes les feuilles
[Musique]
le soir lorsque je termine je suis
complètement épuisé comme si j'avais
joué deux parties de football à 9 heures
après avoir pris quelques bières et bien
je me trancher
[Musique]
castanet
c'est à quel point elle a pas ici à
porto lopez il ne me reste plus que mon
frère c'est la seule personne en qui
j'ai confiance
[Musique]
je me suis fait à ce village il est
pacifique
j'ai du travail les filles sont jolies
et je suis heureux ici
[Musique]
1 ce prestige social et l'auto être
pilote
ces prestigieux les gens admirent car tu
prends des risques et ils te prennent
pour un fou
il ne faut pas que le succès de monte à
la tête
au contraire il faut rester pour ne pas
perdre le contact avec les gens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elisabeth représente la moitié de moi
même si dans mon métier je fais des
folies elle représente pour moi la paix
un oasis dans ma vie quelque part elle
me comprend
elle me protège elle me donne tout son
amour j'ai vraiment besoin d'elle pour
exercer mon métier
si je n'étais pas bien je ne pourrais
pas me concentrer dans ce travail il
faut avoir une grande forme physique et
mentale et des situations de tous les
dangers
elisabeth représentent 70% du monde et
amant tu me la bible l'éternel a parlé à
moïse tout ce que tu peux faire c'est le
selon des forces car dans le zéro c'est
quoi le lion la mort lorsque je lis la
bible
j'apprends tous les jours quelque chose
elle me rassure car ce qui s'est passé
avec le moteur de mon avion et le risque
s'accroît plus je dois être en communion
alors je ne crains rien il n'ya que dieu
que je crains
j'ai mis ma vie entre sa voix
[Musique]
parquet français j'aime pas que josé vol
dans cet avion en mauvais état c'est un
professionnel
c'est à lui de savoir ce qu'il doit
faire je connais bien son avion c'est ce
qui est bien ou pas bien
[Musique]
elisabeth c'est que j'aime coin des
filles mais ce n'est pas sérieux
[Musique]
je ne lui cache rien
notre relation est solide et chacun sait
ce qui l'attend mains de l'eau donne moi
la première l'aide de ton prénom et je
te dirai qu'on tu t'appelles le machisme
a toujours été et sera toujours cet
écrit dans la bible que l'homme sera
supérieur à la femme
pardew
et encore cassé c'est surtout en dessous
du moteur il ya une nouvelle fissure
c'est le mécano qui l'a dit il faudrait
que tu ailles voir tout de suite je
vraiment abusé de cet avion
la fait deux mois que je ne devrais plus
voler avec ce moteur est maintenant il
tombe en panne tout le temps
cette fois ci c'est grave une fissure tu
parles
la fissure est là sous le moteur lui il
s'échappe par ici de la voile bol écoute
je vais faire ce vol pour 700 francs
mais si je m'écrase au sol avec cet
avion
ça te coûtera 700 mille francs tu remets
3 0 7 cent mille francs c'est le prix de
l'avion
non non c'est beaucoup trop de risques
pour mon portefeuille et tu portes à vis
de toute façon les risques on les prend
tout le temps ça fait partie du travail
mais au moins que les clients paient ok
ça marche je peux me payer d'avancé
[Musique]
suicidaire il ne faut pas que l'avion
vole dans cet état c'est vraiment du
suicide
[Musique]
à
lorsqu'on s'ennuie dans la vie il faut
prendre des risques
la vie prend alors beaucoup de valeur
lorsque j'ai terminé le travail
je passe sous les lignes à haute tension
parfois aussi j'atterris sur la route
cela m'excite je domine ma machine la
mort je la sens proche
je joue avec elle mais je la respecte
dix ont fait une fête à l'hacienda avec
des copains tu viens je termine ce chant
et je vous rejoins j'ai encore deux
trois passages à faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
josé il est vraiment dingue
ok mais yano ce sont les plus grandes
étendues de terres salon représente la
moitié de la colombie s'il ya les plus
grandes hacienda du pays pour 20 mille
hectares on met dessus 20000 tête de
l'état que failli me désarçonné avec ton
avion
résultat une vache est cassé la patte eh
bien on n'a qu'à manger la vache
maintenant viens je t'invite à déjeuner
[Musique]
eros passe toute la journée à cheval à
cheval ils londres et c'est eux mêmes
ils sont le symbole des ja nous comme
les cowboys aux états unis dis moi on
est en train de préparer mille hectares
de riz pour avril alors on voudrait que
tu nous punir toute cette partie
oui bien sûr
[Musique]
l'avion pour moi c'est comme pour le
cowboy son cheval je communie avec lui
mon cheval part à gauche tu le redresse
et bien l'avion c'est pareil
pour se faire payer par les agriculteurs
c'est tout un problème regarde cette
liste toi qui es belle ne vont pas
refuser de payer je dois aller les
chercher chez eux dans les bars et les
chercher dans les champs avec une gueule
de chien battu en plan même lorsqu'ils
me voient comme ça certains ne veulent
pas payer tout de suite d'autres me
disent qu'ils n'ont pas d'argent c'est
embêtant
elle est bien m'a dit ça peut être toi
ou ton père 4000 francs qu'est ce que
c'est que ça c'est une facture oui de la
filiation
je peux me régler avec ce que tu as des
vaches des chèvres cheikh n'importe quoi
qui est la valeur
ma maison oui si tu as de jolies filles
à l'intérieur tu trois accidents graves
et beaucoup de mes amis pilotes se sont
tués
j'ai cassé déjà deux avions lors d'un
décollage le moteur a lâché et je me
suis écrasé sur une colline
j'ai été j'ai pris avec le siège grâce à
dieu comment s'appelait l'endroit où tu
es tombé le schéma davanture non non non
c'était une fosse à purin un jour en
plein vol
j'ai rencontré un essaim d'abeilles qui
s'est engouffrée dans le moteur
saleilles tout fait et je suis tombé de
70 m je n'ai rien eu c'est un miracle
grâce à dieu
par contre l'avion
[Musique]
et
or j'ai perdu toute ma famille dans la
catastrophe du volcan d'armero et j'ai
vécu une autre tragédie qui apportera un
être cher s'est suicidé
un jour peut-être je rencontrerai jésus
qu'ils n'emmènent là haut dans le ciel
en fait lorsque je vole je me sens plus
prêt
[Musique]